foreign
[Music]
for explaining to my friend that horses
do have weight limits it sounds like a
good one already I live and work on my
parents horse ranch where we have six
quarter horses that normally weigh six
six quarter horses like a quarter of a
type of horse I guess uh they normally
weigh 900 to 1200 pounds the safe and
comfortable weight to be carried in
these horses is no more than 250 pounds
I'm obese right now and I'm currently on
a weight loss Journey myself so I do not
ride these horses myself because I know
that I exceed the way that's comfortable
for them a few days ago my friend Carly
came over to the ranch to help out she
asked if she could ride one of these
horses Carly weighs more than I do she's
also on a weight loss journey and I
explained to her that horses have a
weight limit and that's why I don't ride
them either she got very quiet and then
left she texted me later saying I was an
for calling her fat am I the
well it's definitely a wake-up
call okay when you're too fat the right
to ride a horse that's that's a way
wake-up call I see you got away from
can't wait to eat um and it goes to show
by the way that morbid obesity is a
modern invention this is something that
we invented in modern times it didn't
exist before like it just didn't it just
almost nowhere in the world could you
find it for most of human history uh
because if you were morbidly obese in
the 1800s you'd have to walk the Oregon
Trail and probably be good for you if
you did you wouldn't lose some weight
now are you the a-hole for preventing
your obese friend from turning your
horse into a horse pancake not at all
um I'm I'm not much of an animal rights
guy but I absolutely believe that
preventing spinal injuries to your horse
is more important than protecting your
friends feelings but your friend is
infected with his modern attitude which
says that uh that you you're not allowed
to acknowledge uncomfortable realities
about other people or about yourself
even if your refusal to acknowledge
those realities could do real damage to
both man and Beast uh you're under no
obligation to play along with that game
though and ignore reality so your friend
is the a-hole for trying to make you
play that game you call your friend and
told this instant
[Music]
am I the for venmo requesting
money from a Tinder date after he
crapped in my car
all right now we're getting into the
nitty-gritty here a couple weeks ago I
19 year old female went on a Tinder date
with a guy who I knew from high school
we were mutual acquaintances before this
and when we matched on Tinder we agreed
to meet up pick them up at seven and we
went and got some food after that we
drove to some secluded place so we could
talk with extra privacy leave it up to
the imagination anyway around 10 30 he
starts to complain about his stomach
hurting I asked him if he wants to leave
and he says no and kind of blows it off
for a little bit around 11 he says he
really needs to use the bathroom I
wasn't sure what to do because we were
in a very secluded area and I wasn't
familiar with he tells me that there's a
gas station about 15 minutes away from
us and asks me to step on it I leave and
drive as fast as I can but it's very
dark I don't know my way around it he's
becoming more more frantic visibly
sweating breathing heavy at one point I
asked if I should pull over because
going in the woods is better than
nothing but he swears he could make it
unfortunately he misses telling me to
take a turn somewhere and we get lost I
have to turn around and it's probably
like 10 more minutes according to him
then he gets very pale and yells at me
to pull over and I stop as fast as I can
but what I do he doesn't get out of the
car he just sits very resigned
at that point I understood it was too
late I came to understand it was too
loud I wonder how you understood that we
both sat there in silence for a little
bit I really wasn't sure what to say to
make him feel better oh man this is a
nightmare and I was also feeling a
little sick from the whole thing
parentheses the smell thank you for
clarifying that because I wouldn't have
known eventually I just offered to take
him home and tried to act nonchalant try
to act nonchalant while this guy is
sitting in his own you know just be
on just be cool about it he agreed so I
drove us home he also tells me that he
will reimburse me for getting my car
cleaned I felt bad because of course it
wasn't his fault accidents happen so I
offered to split the cost 50 50 and we
never talk about it again I also told
him if he if he wants I'd like to try a
second date
wow
you
all right they're very forgiving or have
very low standards or both since this
one turned out uh not so well he thanked
me and we parted ways I got my car
detailed and sent him a text letting him
know everything went well but I didn't
get a response I waited for another week
and tried texting him again like hey did
you see my text and again he didn't
respond I went on Tinder to try and
message him there but I saw he had
unmatched me it was pretty clear that he
had ghosted me I was pretty pissed not
gonna lie because I thought I was chill
about the whole situation it's cool if
he didn't want to see me again but he
could have still kept up his end of the
deal I went looking for his Instagram to
try and message him there and when I
find I see he had his venmo in his bio I
decided to venmo request in the
description I put the poop emoji the
pointed finger and my car communicating
now in hieroglyphics you know because
regular communication hasn't worked
surprisingly I get a quick response he
sends the money but he also texts me
pissed because he said his friends would
be able to see what I put and would
probably put two and two together
um I told him I wouldn't have done that
if he hadn't goes to me am I the
okay well
that was uh
that was a story you know
first of all this is what you get
for having the girl Drive
is one of the many reasons why you as
the man should be taking control of the
situation if you are the one who's
driving then you would have more control
of the situation this probably wouldn't
happen
but beyond that I you know I'm not
really sure I'm kind of torn on this
who's the in the store I mean
there's there's definitely one
in the story a very a very active one
you're a sick but um beyond that
particular I mean
I can't blame you for for not wanting to
have to foot the bill to clean the
stains in your car
but at the same time I can't really
blame the other guy for for hiding away
in shame
it's hard for me to blame him for that
part of it
what else are you gonna do
I mean you texted him and said
everything you texted him and said after
you got the car cleaned he texted him
and said everything went well
went well with cleaning from your
upholstery how do you even respond to
that as the guy you insensitive
what's he supposed to say
thumbs up emoji smiley face cool
congrats on cleaning up my
so there's no good answer here and this
is but this is also here's here's
another thing
this is why
you know I'm so glad that I'm married
so that I can in my car without judgment
also because if you're married and
you're in that situation and we've all
been in situations like that when you're
in the car there's a little bit of a
bathroom emergency but if you're married
now you can have an honest conversation
in a situation like that you could just
say when you're dating right and you
just met this person or you're going
your first date you don't want to be
honest about it and so that's when the
crisis starts but when you're married
you'll just say listen I'm going to
my pants if you don't find me a bathroom
within five minutes
all right um so who's this so I you know
I I guess it's got to be him he is the
guy who shoot your car after all
[Music]
right finally am I the answer for
calling the police on my fiance
my fiance 28 male and I 30 female have
been together for three years I used to
live close to work and use public
transportation but after I moved in to
his house which is hours away from work
I bought myself a car since I'm a nurse
and also since there isn't any hospitals
close to where we live that I could
transfer to you know one thing about
about these things is that um
all of these people are for
giving way too much information we don't
need any of this background still go in
this let's just get to the story
please
my fiance's car hasn't been able to work
for close to two months now it requires
so much money to get it fixed and he
refused my financial help when I offered
it instead he would ask to use my car
every now and then and I agreed as long
as it's when I'm not working and also
since he only uses it for trips to the
supermarket Etc
on New Year's Eve he told me he wanted
to use my car to go hang out with his
friends and celebrate but I declined
because I had to cover a night shift and
needed my car to travel to work he
insisted and even suggested that I take
the night off or swap shifts with
another nurse but I couldn't do that at
the last minute oh my gosh Okay blah
blah blah fast forwarding she doesn't
want to give the car up and he decides
to take it anyway without asking her and
he drives off to go to his New Year's
party she tries to call him and uh and
can't get a hold of him and then finally
does talk to him 30 minutes later and
she's pissed so she calls the cops to
report him from stealing the car okay
and now she's he's mad
are you the for that uh and then
he also says that he can take the car
and she shouldn't have called the police
because they're engaged and so he says
what's what's yours is mine what's mine
is yours
who's this well he's obviously the
he did steal the car you told him not to
you asked him to bring it back he didn't
bring it back you called the police
uh that's probably farther than I would
have taken it but I think it's Justified
but here's the main point
uh no it's not true that as an Engaged
couple what's yours is mine what's mine
is yours that's not true that's marriage
so you don't get to take advantage of
that before the marriage even happens
that there isn't like this grace period
ahead of time
that's in marriage once you be that's
again the point of marriage now you
share everything
and then if you take now it's the family
car and if your spouse calls the police
on you for taking the family car even if
they don't agree with what you're doing
with it
um then that's a different story
so get married is the uh is the moral of
the story
and then you can steal your spouse's car
all you want
and even in it if you want
[Music]